I applied to the city in early 2014
to turn my coin-operated laundry into housing.
We sit at ground zero of anti-gentrification
in San Francisco.
No monsters in the Mission!
Getting this property approved has so far
taken
longer than it took the United States to win
World War 2.
I’ve spent $1.2 million.
Whose city?
Our city!
The Board of Supervisors denied the project
because it cast a partial shadow on an adjacent schoolyard.
If you’re wondering why housing in San Francisco
is expensive,
they make it expensive here.
It is intentional.
Sky-high rents in San Francisco...
They pay $7000 a month...
...a 54% rent increase
It’s just been such a steady climb...
...dramatically in the last 5 to 10 years
It’s astounding...
A sky-high new record...
A once working class neighborhood transformed...
San Francisco has become the most expensive city to live in
in the nation.
As its population has boomed over the past few decades,
developers have found it almost impossible to build new housing.
The story of one small developer, in particular,
shines a light on what’s gone wrong in
the Golden Gate City.
San Francisco is the worst place in the country to try to do development,
and the Mission is the worst place in San Francisco.